a Oasys boyfriend goes viral for
castigating his fellow white people as
hopelessly racist we will examine the
dangers of toxic effeminacy then squad
member Ayanna Presley winds on the floor
of the house Elizabeth Warren takes
money from a broke student and president
Trump teaches us all a lesson when the
media asked him what lessons he learned
from impeachment all that plus the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
ooh we got a lot to get to today not
gonna give you a lot of hope for
Millennials but maybe maybe a lesson for
our whole culture we'll get to all that
in a second first I got to thank our
friends a new sponsor to the show over
at fairway meat market you know me I
pretty much eat a carnivorous diet my my
diet is pretty much meats and
occasionally a little bit of cheese and
some booze fairway meat market is a
family-owned grocery chain that has been
in business since 1938
where each and every cut his hand cut by
their highly experienced team of
butchers you know I was in DC for about
three weeks I was shooting that my other
podcast verdict with Ted Cruz I come
back and fairway had sent me this
amazing selection of meat of beef
premium beef all-natural pork which is
raised by family farmers and sourced
straight out of corn country which gives
you access to the highest quality meat
in America they got ribs they got rib
eyes they got pork chops they got beef
tenderloin they got every style and cut
that your kitchen can possibly handle
and fairway meat market calm also has
the best recipes it's got great cooking
tips to make sure that you and your
friends and your family have a meal that
they won't forget go get it these guys
are so so cool this week my listeners
can get the heartland package value to
230 bucks for just $99.99 plus you get
free shipping when you enter Knolls que
no wles a check at Heartland package
includes eight 8-ounce all-natural
boneless pork chops six eight ounce USDA
choice ribeye steaks one mouth-watering
side dish loaded potato baked gourmet
cheesy corn or brisket baked beans
that's more than 50% off the best meat
in America Plus free shipping that is
fairway meat market comp remote code
Knowles and look at for the Heartland
package all right AOC he o C and her
boyfriend I wasn't ever going to mention
a o C's boyfriend because you know you
know you you want to think that
boyfriends and girlfriends and wives and
husbands are off-limits that's a rule I
generally abide by except sometimes
politicians decide to thrust their
significant others into the political
spotlight
and AOC has done this more than anyone
she's just put her boyfriend on camera
on the internet to parrot her political
points of view
trouble is the the points of view that
she's having him espouse are not only
wrong they're absolutely humiliating for
her boyfriend here is AOC and her love
interest
Riley what has been helpful to you in
combating racism I think it's helpful
and important to talk to other white
people about racism and I think a lot of
people they don't want to be racist they
don't think that they're racist but they
also don't know some of the things that
they believe or say are and can be
racist and I think one of the like
effective ways is just to talk and kind
of help teach them about why some of the
things they believe or say or think are
wrong not necessarily racist or that
they're wrong and that'll sort of like
chip away and you know contribute to
some development in this area but not
necessarily take somebody from like
being a racist and not being a racist in
one company it's just always being open
to learning about racist things that we
may have said or done without judgment
and defensiveness if you couldn't if
you're if you're listening if you if you
haven't seen this video you could
probably hear it but a o'seas boyfriend
is like the whitest guy who has ever
walked the face of the earth very
light-skinned and red hair and he's he's
very white and the irony here is that
his thesis which is really her thesis I
suspect because she's sitting there
filming him waiting for him to say kind
of nodding along when she approves the
irony is that his thesis is racist right
his his thesis is that a group of people
are flawed by their skin color and
they're flawed pretty much irreparably
right his his idea is that white people
are by definition
and it's it's all of them right they're
the ones who don't know that they're
racist are probably the most racist of
all and that you can't really fix it he
says you're you're not going to make
someone not a racist overnight or over a
few days meaning that either no matter
how much you talk to them they'll still
always be this vestigial racism they're
sort of depraved to their core and all
you can do is try to try to help the
problem along a little bit that's the
irony of the clip the sadder part of the
clip is that he's participating in this
at all the sadder part of the clip is
that he is allowing his girlfriend to
humiliate him in front of millions of
people that's humiliating right to have
your girlfriend's holding a camera to
her millions of followers and basically
saying okay tell everyone how bad you
are and tell everyone how bad everyone
who looks like you is and tell everyone
how they're never really going to get
better and when you say something I
agree with I'll not approvingly
but you better say it it's like a like a
forced confession and under a
dictatorship or something it's so
humiliating it's not respectful this is
toxic effeminacy okay we hear a lot
about toxic masculinity this is toxic
effeminacy and it's funny I'm doing the
Prager you book show so we're doing once
a month we read one of these great books
and talk about it with people the one
that we're just about to film is the
book of Genesis and the book of Genesis
actually has a lot to say about toxic
masculinity and about toxic effeminacy
this video of aoc and her boyfriend is
like a live-action production of the
third chapter of the book of Genesis
right in the book of Genesis God tells
Eve after even Adam have sinned and God
is doling out their punishment God tells
Eve as part of her punishment her desire
shall be for her husband and what that
statement means is that she will she
will have a kind of appetite for her
husband she'll want to control her
husband she'll want to devour him I mean
think of like a praying mantis you know
the female praying mantis devouring the
male and
in the act of love that's the the
punishment for Eve then he tells Adam as
his punishment that Adam will have to
toil the earth this tells you about two
flaws categorically in men and women
that's the the flaw for women in this
chapter is that women will want to
domineer they'll want to
they'll have desire for their man
they'll want to devour their man and
that the flow of men is that they're
lazy okay those are the two flaws being
domineering being lazy actually in in
that very chapter when when God is
doling out the punishment to Eve the
punishment is you your desire will be
for your husband but he shall rule over
you and some people reading this for the
first time might say oh it looks like
he's giving Eve a punishment but Adam a
reward his Adam gets to rule over Eve
not really the that's a misreading of
Adam's desires Adam's desire here and
the desire that is therefore being
described of all men is not to rule over
people actually the the real desire of
men is to sit on the couch and eat
potato chips and watch TV and it's
actually a punishment that he will rule
over her it's a punishment for both of
them
toxic effeminacy toxic masculinity
obviously in this clip you were seeing
this guy's girlfriend just totally
domineer him humiliate him mock him on
video
but the flaw you're also seeing that
same masculine flaw in in his
performance because he's just going
along with it he's just lazy shrinking
into himself he's being cowed he's he's
allowing himself to be humiliated
because he doesn't want to stand up for
himself compare that video to a video of
our president President Trump was asked
during a press conference yesterday I
believe it was what lessons he had
learned from impeachment this is a
question being asked by the media
assuming a democratic and anti Trump
Republican premise which is the Trump
needed to learn a lesson and so they
don't even say did you learn a lesson
they jump right past accepting the
premise into saying
what lesson did you learn from
impeachment and Trump shoves it right
back in their face Lisa Murkowski
earlier said that you shouldn't got
involved with the Roger stone case she
said it's just bad some Republicans have
said they hoped you would learn a lesson
from impeachment what lesson did you
learn from impeachment that the
Democrats are crooked they've got a lot
of crooked things going that they're
vicious that they shouldn't have brought
impeachment my call numbers are ten
points higher because of fake news like
NBC which reports the news very
inaccurately probably more inaccurately
than CNN if that's possible
MS DNC and your MS and if you take a
look at NBC now I think they're among
the most dishonest reporters of the news
absolutely the right answer thank you
mr. Trump for showing us how to shove
this right back in their face
he the question that's being asked more
or less is hey mr. Trump when did you
stop beating your wife right it's it's a
question where anyway you answer you're
accepting the premise and it makes you
look bad the premise being you needed to
learn a lesson from impeachment because
you made a big mistake and he just says
no I'm not taking your premise here's
the lesson I learned as you people are
all corrupt you people are all absolute
hacks and you're incompetent too because
you tried to take me out and instead my
poll numbers or ten points higher that
is some virtuous masculine it adds
manliness that's standing up for
yourself shoving it right back at them
not allowing yourself to be humiliated
and cowed on national television an
important lesson and it
I guess one way to recognize that there
can be a virtue to manliness too just
like there can be toxicity to effeminacy
is to realize that there are some toxic
women out there too there's some toxic
men there's some toxic women there's
racism from one race there's racism from
other races too we'll get to all of that
in a second first I've got to thank our
friends over at ring rings mission you
know what it is it's to make
neighborhoods safer now you probably
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a surprise
visitor maybe your mother-in-law's
something like that if there's a pack
delivery or if there's a burglar trying
to do you harm I don't know which one is
scarier you will get an alert you'll be
able to see here and speak to them all
from your phone doesn't matter where you
are in your home and your bedroom in
your office in your beach house wherever
you are you can check in on your home as
a subscriber you have a special offer on
a ring welcome kit available right now
ring comma slash Knolls Canada LS this
kit includes a video doorbell and a
chime Pro which is just what you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home today you know I love ring I
give it out to my friends as
housewarming gifts I really believe in
the product go check it out ring calm /
Knowles kena wles that's ring calm /
Knowles we hear a lot about toxic men we
don't hear about the other side of it
very much so I wanted to highlight a
toxic woman who also went viral
yesterday this is squad member
she's like the the minor member of the
squad she's the Ringo Starr of the squad
Ayanna Presley she took to the floor of
the House of Representatives to wine the
great poet and pioneer righteous rage
audre Lorde once said quote I am NOT
free while any woman is unfree even when
our shackles are different from are very
different from my own n quote the year
is now 2020 and here we women are still
in so many ways not fully free still
shackled today I rise to affirm the
humanity and the dignity of all women I
rise in strong unapologetic righteous
support of HJ Res 79 which will strike
the arbitrary deadline for ratification
of the Equal Rights Amendment an
amendment that should already be the law
of the land the American Constitution is
sexist by its very design ok where do we
even begin with all of this first of all
she she begins she says quoting audre
Lorde's the the pioneer of righteous
rage by the way when people refer to
themselves as righteous that's usually a
good clue that they are being on
righteous but she's coming out and
saying I'm full of rage I'm first she's
just describing this this vice this
awful temptation and then she goes on
and says America's sexist from the very
core and women have no rights in America
and everything's terrible this while
she's standing on the floor of the House
of Representatives this while she's one
of the most prominent members of the
Democratic Party only by virtue of her
association with three other people
AOC Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib all
women by the way who are much more
prominent faces of the Democratic Party
some of the most prominent politicians
in America but women have no rights
absol what what rights do women lack in
America none absolutely none of course
but she's angry and furious anyway and
willing to denounce her whole country
for it she then goes on to endorse the e
ra this is the Equal Rights Amendment
it's got a really nice sounding name but
it's a horrible terrible idea this was a
dumb law that was defeated decades and
decades ago mostly by women one woman in
particular a conservative pioneer named
Phyllis Schlafly and then it's come back
in recent years and it's gaining some
popularity on the Left it's a terrible
idea for a law it would force women into
the draft it would force women to be
drafted into the military it would
absolutely abolish same sex restrooms
and same sex schools in any kind of
same-sex facility and it would enshrine
into law the right to kill babies for
abortion everything about this law is
terrible it was rightly defeated decades
ago now it's coming back up that's the
specific point on the law on the larger
point what these radicals are saying is
that any suggestion that men and women
are in any way different is sexist and
you know by a very narrow definition of
sexism I guess that's true what is what
is sexism is to discriminate to be
discriminating to see differences
between men and women so I guess
technically that is sexist it's not
bigoted it's not harmful it's not
injurious to recognize that men and
women have
biological differences often they have
differences of desire they have but it I
guess there are differences for these
radicals absolutely
that has to be abolished that is a real
form of toxic effeminacy if a man had
gone down to the floor and given that
speech he would be rightly mocked for it
this brings us to another toxic woman
Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren's
campaign in recent days for president
has just collapsed absolutely she's
doing anything she can to try to remain
relevant she told a story on MSNBC last
night about how she's on the campaign
trail and a young girl comes up to her
and says listen I'm completely broke but
I've given you what little money I have
so that you can keep running for
president Elizabeth Warren believes this
is some sort of inspiring story there
are so many people who are in this fight
for all the right reasons
you know me did the speech and then
afterwards did selfie line and we were
there for over an hour people are coming
through and they're saying thank you or
and they're giving hugs and talking
about what's important to them young
woman came up by herself and she said
I'm a broke college student with a lot
of student loan debt and she said I
checked and I have six dollars in the
bank so I just gave three dollars to
keep you in this fight that's what we
got to do we've got to stay in this
fight with people who are counting on us
this isn't about fighting other
Democrats this is about fighting for the
America we believe in you took her money
what kind of monster are you
the poor girl has only got six dollars
in the bank and you a very very wealthy
woman a Harvard professor took half of
her money three dollars what a monster
now I don't think any of her story is
true Elizabeth Warren has a little bit
of a difficult relationship with the
truth difficult relationship with her
DNA lies about her DNA for decades to
get professional advantage lies about
being fired because she was pregnant
lies about sending her kids to public
school it lies about pretty much
everything she's probably lying about
this too but even beyond the story even
the poor
she's making it are not true she says
this race is not about fighting other
Democrats no no it is that's what a
primary campaign is a primary campaign
is when you battle people of your own
party and then one of you gets nominated
and then you battle the people of the
other party also almost certainly untrue
is that the girl had six dollars in the
bank why is that untrue because very few
people have six dollars in the bank
now some people are broke but they don't
have six dollars in the bank some people
maybe they have I don't know $200 in the
bank or a thousand dollars in the bank
and they got a ton of debt so there
they're broke but it's that more than
six dollars in the bank some people are
overdrawn on their bank accounts right
it goes it's in the negative but very
few people have six dollars specifically
in the bank that seems like it was a
number that was constructed to tell a
well ultimately not very convincing
political story if the story is true
Elizabeth Warren should not have taken
the money what is she thinking first of
all her campaign is over more or less
after her dismal performance in New
Hampshire it's probably not going on
very far but also it's just wrong to do
that Liz Warren is not some messianic
religious figure okay Liz Warren is not
she's a politician okay I mean that the
story that she's telling is sort of like
the story of the Widow's mite in the
Gospels you know Christ talks about how
this this Widow this poor Widow gave
what little she had and and gave it as
an offering and that this was worth so
much more than what the wealthy people
had given because she had given so much
of what she had well Elizabeth Warren
isn't Jesus okay this is a sacrifice
that you're offering to God it's making
a donation to some political campaign
and in this case one that's going to
lose that but that is how Elizabeth
Warren is portraying it's so ravenous
it's so filled with rage to use I on a
Presley's term it's so aggressive this
is toxic it stalks
effeminacy different than toxic
femininity okay it's not feminine it's
effeminate it's not womanly it's
womanish what's the difference what
we're seeing here from a OCS boyfriend -
Ayanna Presley - whoever tail is Warren
- we're seeing specifically though among
men in this country is all the worst
characteristics associated with women
with none of the good characteristics
what we're seeing here is that leftism
is intrinsically effeminate all the
worst characteristics of women none of
the good characteristics leftism is not
nurturing it's not beautiful it's not
particularly good at multitasking it's
not fruitful what it is is overbearing
and desirous of dependency it is toxic
now there's a bad kind of masculinity -
right there's there's a masculinity
that's toxic
that's called machismo right Minute Men
have bad tendencies as well as good
tendencies and when you take all the bad
tendencies and just make them all go
together that's that's toxic but our
threat in our culture is not from toxic
masculinity all right we our culture
does not suffer from being too masculine
the threat here is really from toxic
effeminacy and that and you can see that
toxicity in certain women but you see it
in certain men - who are willing to take
all of these awful awful characteristics
and and none of the good ones there's
there's one last example of this that
really shoots down all all of the claims
that a Oasys boyfriend is making really
what makes that video look even more
ridiculous than it already is that's a
story out of UVA where a student they're
speaking at the multicultural Student
Center insisted that the white people
got to get out because there's too many
white people we'll get to that in a
second first got to thank our friends
over it keeps two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 but with
today's advancements in science keeps
offers proven treatments that can combat
the symptoms of hair loss and help you
keep the hair you have and half the cost
of your local pharmacy people think this
is
complicated but it's not you can keep
your hair prevention is key keeps us up
to 90 percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss so the sooner
you start sooner you go get your keeps
the more hair you'll save you so you got
act fast keeps now offers a prescription
shampoo that keeps your scalp healthy
too thanks to keeps you no longer have
to go to the doctor's office for your
hair loss prescription now you can visit
a doctor online get your hair loss
medication delivered directly to your
home if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps calm /
Knowles Cantu wles receive your first
month of treatment for free that is K e
e P s calm / Knowles K no W le s head on
over do it now there's this video just
came out of UVA and it's it's from the
multicultural Student Center the young
America's Foundation obtained the video
I guess a student secretly recorded it
this is of a young gal a woman of color
who stands up there and says that this
is the multicultural Student Center and
therefore it you can't have that many
white people here now you might think
multicultural means all different kind
of cultures all different kind of people
who all look different no that's not how
she's interpreting it she's saying more
or less we need to have a segregated
Student Center and white people need to
get lost
there's just too many white people in
here and this is a space for people of
color so let's be really cognizant of
the space that you're taking up because
it does make some of us pocs
uncomfortable when we see too many white
people in here it's only been open for
four days and frankly there's the whole
University for a lot of jana viet and
there's very few spaces for us so keep
that in mind thank you too many white
people get those white people out of
here so if racism has a definition
anymore in the rate of the left has
pretty much degraded that word down to
nothing but if racism has a definition
that is racist that is the textbook
example of racism you don't hear that
description in the aoc boyfriend video
do you know in the aoc boyfriend video
it's only white people who can ever be
racist who can ever harbor bigotry
and white people can never get rid of it
and nobody else could have it that's so
silly
that's so unbalanced it's so wrong
if you I think there's this idea that
comes out of this toxic effeminacy that
you you've just got to surrender
yourself entire you've just got to give
away any backbone you might have you can
never have an opinion if you're a white
person you're bad if you're a man you're
bad if you're straight you're bad and
your opinions are invalid you can't say
anything and this is based on a theory
of historical injustice and and present
victimhood that comes together in the
left-wing ideology called
intersectionality it's just victim
politics on steroids
and so you see it in a OCS boyfriend he
just says I I just talked to white
people we're just so bad we'll never be
better but I'm trying please I'm trying
you don't see a Ossie make a similar
acknowledgement say you know I'm I've
got my problems too I've got my flaws as
well and maybe I should look into myself
and convince my fellow congresswoman or
my fellow women whoever that that we've
got stuff to work on to now it's only in
one direction
I mean obviously if if a white student
stood up at any center on any university
campus and said hey we don't really like
that there are so many non-white people
here so just for this is a space for
white people and everyone else has to
leave that would be an international
incident you'd have the UN investigating
it or something
but but in this case it only goes in one
direction I think if you want to restore
a sense of justice to the country then
you've got to that you've got to you
can't let it get to an extreme like that
you can't I don't think there's anything
wrong with acknowledging that there are
some bad traits of men and if that's all
that toxic masculinity means okay that's
fine I accept that but likewise you've
got to recognize there is toxic
effeminacy
if you're going to say that one group
can harbour racial biases then you have
to acknowledge that other groups can
Harbor racial biases as well but
unfortunately that's not the situation
we see because because of leftism
because leftism makes it so one side of
it so
domineering it's so ravenous it's so
desirous of consuming everything in its
wake
leftism will not be the answer to that
the irony of that
UVA video is that it's at the
multicultural Student Center the theory
of multiculturalism is that you're gonna
bring everybody together and you're all
going to sing Kumbaya but what's the
practice the practice is actually
increasing racial division actually
increasing a bigotry you see it all
around the idea of feminism is that
everybody is going to be equal in
kumbaya and come together what's the
practice division rancor rage as Ayane
Presley is describing it that is not the
answer we have to restore some balance
and you need to see where the threat
really lies is the threat and toxic
masculinity when you look at those
videos do you think that we have a
surplus of masculinity or does the
threat lie on the opposite end we have
got to get to the mailbag but first I've
got to tell you about a new podcast the
cold war what we saw hosted by our
friend bill Whittle if you love history
and you just despise communism like I do
then you're gonna want to check it out
bill captures what it was like to live
through major events such as the Berlin
Airlift the Korean War the Cuban Missile
Crisis and a space race and and really
what you would call it is the apocalypse
that never happened so if you're around
my age you were not alive for any of
those events the story is told so well
the setting is so brilliantly set that
as you go through these events you will
you'll feel like you were there you'll
start to understand the battle not only
for economic freedom but for
civilization itself so they've already
released two episodes of this 12 part
series and you've got something to catch
up on now so head on over it's a great
time to listen as the 2020 election
starts to heat up and we can see where
the left has gone full-blown commie in
so many of their policies and their
language especially as Bernie Sanders is
beginning to run away with the
Democratic nomination head on over to
daily wire.com slash cold war and start
listening to this incredibly important
story that is daily wired.com slash cold
war head on over now we'll be right back
with the mailbag
all right let's get into the mailbag
from Kyle cordial greetings Michael
Archbishop of the Diocese of The Daily
wire wondering if you can summarize some
of the key political policies of the
Whig party and how they compare to the
two major extant political parties on
which issues would Whigs and Republicans
clash on which contemporary issues with
Whigs and modern Democrats clash love
the show and everything you guys do so
now we have two major parties the
Democrats and the Republicans before
they're Republicans you had two major
parties the Democrats and the Whigs the
the problem with trying to draw an exact
line or analogy between these parties is
that politics change over time this is
one of the struggles of the the Trump
era is you have some kind of boomer
Republicans being really upset that
political positions ever adjust to
changing circumstances those like no we
used to have this policy but now thirty
years later we have this new policy or
we've changed the policy a little bit
but that's what happens in politics so
broadly speaking you could say that the
Republican Party was the successor to
the Whig party that the Whigs were the
forerunner of the Republicans but there
were some there were some similarities
and there were some differences so
though the Whig party broadly was
founded as a kind of Nationalist Party
in that way I guess they have a
similarity to the current Republican
Party they had a lot of support in the
north but they actually the Whigs did
fairly well in the south as well they
had a real ability to compete there the
Whigs were founded on law and order the
waves were founded on preserving
tradition the Whigs were founded on in
many ways they were the successor of the
Federalist Party which was the kind of
founding party of America and wrote the
defend of the Constitution the Democrats
accused the Whigs of being the
successors to the Federalist Party and
so in that way there's a real similarity
to the Republican Party now maybe a
difference would be that the Whigs
very Pro tariffs they were founded as a
pro tariff party and if you thought
about the Republican Party from say 1950
to 2015 you would say they were the anti
tariff party but even that doesn't tell
the whole story because the modern
Republican Party from the days of
Abraham Lincoln was Pro tariffs Abraham
Lincoln said you give me a tariff I'll
give you the greatest nation on earth
then in the middle of the twentieth
century became very anti tariffs now
it's kind of Pro tariffs again under
President Trump or at least it's unclear
you can't tell if he just wants to use
tariffs as a strategy or if he thinks or
as a tactic rather to negotiate or if he
thinks that it's actually good for the
economy that's a long answer to a simple
question but what I really want to show
you here is that political parties are
not so simple and they're not stagnant
they don't stay remain exactly the same
as they always were they develop over
time this is why the Democrats say that
the Republican and the Democratic
parties switched they didn't really
switch of course no one came together
one day and said hey from now on you
Democrats are gonna be Republicans and
we Republicans are gonna be Democrats
that obviously is ridiculous they didn't
really switch on their core principles
either the Republican Party was founded
to defend freedom is founded on the
issue of slavery and they've taken that
principle throughout the course of their
existence but regional support has
changed over time the Democratic Party
has become far leftist and that
irritated people who were slightly more
socially conservative and so some of
them especially in the south became
Republican they change over time that is
why occasionally political parties
collapse like the wigs and new parties
come up to address new challenges like
the Republicans from Michael hey Michael
when arguing religion with someone the
other day they challenged me to prove
Jesus was a real person without pointing
to the Bible my question to you is other
than religious texts is there any proof
that Jesus was a real person
thank you yes I think it's kind of silly
to say hey ignore the most famous texts
about this person that rely on 500
eyewitnesses which is what we're talking
about when we're talking about the New
Testament but even so there are
non-christian sources that attest to the
existence of Jesus most prominent is
probably the Jewish historian Joseph
who wrote an account of Jesus within
sixty years of the crucifixion so within
a lifetime of the crucifixion Josephus
new people and spoke to people who had
seen and heard Jesus so he he was
exposed to these first-hand accounts the
historian Tacitus writing about 80 years
after the crucifixion wrote an account
of Jesus so also you know about within a
lifetime this was also around the same
time that the Roman governor Pliny the
Younger
wrote about Jesus and also around the
same time that the historian Suetonius
refers to Jesus so there are multiple
non scriptural sources of the existence
of Jesus and because of that at level
certainly because of that but even on
its own I would I would then say you
shouldn't be so quick to dismiss the New
Testament accounts because the New
Testament accounts are written by people
who had seen Jesus who had heard Jesus
in her knew Jesus's from page hey
Michael
when I was growing up in Central Texas
my father worked for a large company
that had at least one family oriented
activity a year my husband and I work in
a major tech company that has numerous
employee activities however nothing is
family focused family isn't invited at
all during your shows you guys were
talking about nuclear families and how
they've changed over the years why do
you think companies have shifted to not
include the employees families do you
think it has something to do with the
cultural shift of having kids later in
life my husband also points out how
almost nobody wants anything to do with
their co-workers outside of the office
look forward to hearing what you think
that's an excellent question the reason
that family oriented events have fallen
apart at companies is because the the
left has given us political correctness
and the left has attempted pretty
successfully to destroy the family and
those two have to go hand-in-hand
because now it's considered politically
incorrect to refer to somebody's wife or
husband if you assume that somebody
would have a wife or husband you're
assuming their sexual preferences you're
assuming that they don't want to remain
single for their whole lives
your
you're assuming a moral order that is
traditional that we can all participate
in the left has attacked the family by
redefining the family right by
redefining marriage itself for all of
human history everywhere in the world
sexual difference was fundamental to the
definition of marriage marriage had to
involve husbands and wives and then
within the last seven or eight years
the left completely obliterated that now
we don't really know what the definition
of marriage is they've redefined it to
just be monogamous unions of either
people who are the same sex or different
sex but even that is kind of dissolving
now there are laws being considered in
this country to legalize polygamy now
there are throuple x' including for
members of Congress who are in kind of
unconventional relationships so that
definition has just completely broken
down as conservatives predicted that it
would the other aspect of this though by
breaking down the the moral order and by
breaking down traditional social mores
is it's it's all been pursuit in pursuit
of a hyper individualism the left has
always gone after this might seem
counterintuitive because the left also
loves collectivism basically forcing
everyone under the federal government
forcing everyone into these collectives
but the first step to bringing anyone
under a collective is to destroy all the
barriers to that namely local
attachments and the most local
attachment which is the attachment to
the family so that then you get a
society of just atomized individuals who
have no relation to one another
whatsoever and then they can all brought
be brought together again under a
collective so now you have a lot of
employee events because we're all just
viewed as individuals and we can never
presume that anybody's got any sort of
attachments to anybody else
that's the leftist dream I mean it
Justice Anthony Kennedy when he was
running the Planned Parenthood the Casey
decision he said that the Constitution
gives us a right to define reality as we
see fit I don't know where in the
Constitution he found that but that's
that's I think the end of the leftist
dream is that we want to redefine
reality itself that's the end
of hyper individualism and it would make
you mad if you if you didn't have any
reality to grab onto if you were just
kind of swimming in your own head and
your own fantasies that would truly
drive you insane but I guess it has for
many people on the left and that's why
you're not gonna see it anytime soon
it's also why conservatives need to
recognize that the cultural issues are
the most important ones and the
political or economic issues fall
downstream of that if we don't defend
traditional institutions if we don't
defend our cultural inheritance if we
don't defend the family itself then all
those other things that we want are
going to be meaningless because the left
will have won the decisive battle from
Paul
I'm Michael big fan here my sister and
brother-in-law recently contacted my
wife and I to let us know that my 15
year old niece wants to transition to a
boy and after going to group counseling
for a while they're going to support her
I had many thoughts on this and I do
feel comfortable approaching my sister
about that decision my question is
should I she's not my child so it's not
really my place but she is my niece and
I've heard stories of increased suicide
rates for trans teens I'd hate for
something like that to happen and for me
to have said nothing that may have
helped prevent it so should I say
something Thanks yes you should prevent
it you should say something at least you
should say that boys cannot magically
become girls girls cannot magically
become boys men and women are different
you should say that the ideology that is
behind transgenderism is extraordinarily
new and it's changing all the time and
it's internally contradictory because on
the one hand we're told the gender is
nothing gender is socially constructed
it doesn't matter at all on the other
hand we're told that gender is so innate
so important so so essential that we've
got to go through expensive and painful
mutilations to try to to try to make our
bodies fit closer to our minds you
should show your family that the idea of
gender and sex being different doesn't
make any sense because the ideology
tells us that sex is biological you know
I'm I look like a man I've got male
genitalia I've got a wife
but gender is in the mind it's it's not
physical it's actually metaphysical but
of course if that were true would be
much easier just to change your mind
right because it's a lot simpler to
change your minds than it is to go
through these expensive mutilations
except when you tell that to people who
push this gender ideology they then
completely move the goalposts and they
say no no it's not just in your mind
it's physical - it's in your brain
people who are born with who are have a
male sex but a female gender their
brains actually look more like women but
if you say okay if it's in the brain
that's physical then so it's biological
as well and then this distinction
between sex and gender completely breaks
down and then on the most personal level
what you should tell them is that the
pioneer of the transgender surgery dr.
Paul McHugh at Johns Hopkins head of
psychiatry at Johns Hopkins started the
gender clinic there and he shut it down
he shut it down years later because he
realized it was medical malpractice
because he realized that would you cite
those high rates of suicide among
teenagers with gender dysphoria which is
a real condition those high rates of
suicide did not go down after the
surgery rates of stress anxiety
depression even suicidality did not go
down the surgery did nothing and in some
cases it caused profound regret we're
now seeing huge rates of regret of
people who have a transition so-called
orb in transition and you should tell
them that 15 year-olds are not in the
position to make these kinds of
decisions that could that will
inevitably affect the rest of their
lives we have an age of consent for a
reason right if you if you're a 25 year
old guy and you sleep with a 15 year old
girl you'll go to jail right Lee
you'll go to jail because 15 year olds
are deemed not able to make those sorts
of decisions that could affect the rest
of their lives but what on earth does a
one-night stand compared with
fundamentally mutilating your body and
going on hormones and stopping puberty
and making yourself infertile I mean
it's a one-night stand is as far less
permanent deleterious effects
and doing something like radically
changing your body so by any standard by
any measure what what the gender
ideology movement is doing to teenagers
is criminal it's immoral it is
indefensible and it is ruining lives and
you should at least present that kind of
information to your family if really so
that you can try to help your niece but
if for no other reason so that you can
rest easy and let your conscience go
easy that you did what you could
to stop this terrible idea all right
from anonymous I was reading a o'seas
profile on Wikipedia and it says she
graduated from Boston University with
honors in international relations and
economics I find it very difficult to
believe that AOC has a degree in
economics is there any way to confirm
that she has a degree in econ from bu if
so remind me not to send my kids there
thanks I would appear that she does have
a degree in economics from bu and
perhaps you shouldn't send your kids
there or perhaps she was just a terrible
student the real problem is not just to
be you but at universities all around
the country standards have fallen so
dramatically and grade inflation has
gotten so rampant that you can graduate
you can graduate now from Yale with a
degree in English summa [ __ ] laude and
not have read at William Shakespeare
okay that's a press tab' you problem
that is a problem at universities
overall and it means that maybe when
you're thinking about which school your
kid's gonna go to you're gonna have a
much harder issue than just avoiding BU
last question from Nick I have a common
problem I really enjoy having a cigar on
the weekends the issue is my girlfriend
doesn't approve and said it's either her
or the cigars with all the extra money I
have now which cigar brands should I
stock up on thanks a great question
you should stock up on my father you
should stack up on Ted wha-hey and
padrone and floor dominicana you
obviously have the right idea on this
and it's an idea that I think you have
received from the great poet Rudyard
Kipling who wrote a famous poem on this
called the betrothed it's one of my
favorite poems and it's a it's about how
a guy has to choose between his fiancee
Maggie
and his cigar his fiancee Maggie has
given him an ultimatum and he's got to
choose and the poem goes on and on and
on it's very profound but it it
concludes a million surplus Maggie's are
willing to bear the yoke and a woman is
only a woman but a good cigar is a smoke
light me another Cuba I hold to my first
sworn vows if Maggie will have no rival
I'll have no Maggie for spouse that's
our show
that's our week we'll be coming back on
Monday in the meantime I am going to go
smoke a cigar
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show see you next week
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producers
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
assistant director pavel madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson
hair and makeup Jessa alvera production
assistants McKenna Waters and Ryan love
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]